[Musique]
la vraie comité d'accueil qui a été mis
en place qui est un comité d'accueil qui
a été fait à l'appel des antilles pas de
lyon qui ne souhaite pas que sur la
place voilà une semaine du vote des
militants et l'air renaud muselier
annonce son choix je fais un choix
personnel soutenir xavier bertrand ils
respectent nos valeurs contrairement à
certains de nos cadres à marine le pen
présidente de la république je pense que
le quartier c'est un peu plus tenus ça
veut dire qu'on n'aurait pas des cinq
comme ça là où on l on tente les anti
fades et où les antifas 10 ne rentrait
pas sur ça mais les antilles soit les
antifas ils doivent être dissous
monsieur soutire représente l'extrême
intérêt notre famille politique et comme
il représente cette évolution à
l'intérieur je demande une explication
dans ma famille politique ne critiquez
pas une attaque en règle quant à eric
ciotti je ne lui ai jamais contesté du
talent du talent pour envoyer des
signaux à l'extrême droite il en est le
faux nez c'est une faute morale et
politique les attaques qu'il fait
contraire intiative c'est tout
simplement pas possible c'est pas
acceptable je gagne le 4 décembre je
ferai campagne avec michel barnier et
valérie pécresse avec philippe blain est
avérée eric ciotti que ça plaise ou non
à certains c'est ça l'esprit de
rassemblement et comme si lille
interview par rapport à ma position sur
ces idées d'extrême droite internat
famille politique et à ce moment là et
vous l'avez dit sur tille assommé
monsieur bertrand baudaire concours
lépine de la radicalité qu'offre le
débat de la primaire des républicains
bertrand a pris une option sérieuse pour
le podium je vois bien les petits
télégraphistes mais de l'elysée qui sont
mandatés par les de renaud muselier ben
vous l'avez reconnu que la meinau vous
l'avez reconnu parce que renaud muselier
vient de déclarer que je vais quitter
l'est républicain vous nous annoncez que
vous quitter je dirais plus partie il
n'y était plus déjà c'est une
clarification je salue parce que pour
une fois il est il est honnête ça fait
trois ans qu'ils travaillent pour un
marbre vous êtes un homme blessé ce
matin n'ont ju malheureux tu malheureux
parce que c'est la fin d'une belle
histoire
guy bienvenue pense que ça sa place elle
est dans cette majorité comme d'ailleurs
beaucoup de personnes que je connais qui
sont encore aux républicains je suis si
vous croyez que c'est monsieur mâcon qui
m'a dit de faire ça ben je vous pose la
question les amis et jacobin et
l'expérience que je vais livrer
aujourd'hui montre que dans le monde
dans lequel on vit
être innocent ne permet plus de dormir
tranquille alors qu'il est mis en cause
par plusieurs femmes pour des faits de
harcèlement et d'agressions sexuelles
des témoignages diffusés demain soir sur
notre antenne dans l'émission envoyé
spécial
nicolas hulot a pris la parole ce matin
à la télévision ni de près ni de loin
je n'ai commis ces actes
ils sont ces affirmations sont purement
mensonge heures je le dis ici une fois
pour toutes je peux vous dire qu'il ya
une mineure par niel a été agressé dans
ce cas la tabbee n'a pas demandé une
adulte aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
mineurs au moment des faits qu'il a mal
acquis qui détaillera justement son
témoignage demain dans la manière
qu'elles ont de raconter ce qu'elles
disent avoir subi il ya vraiment des
ressemblances il ya vraiment des
témoignages qui effectivement se font
écho je quitte définitivement la vie
publique tout simplement parce que je
suis écoeuré
et puis on a appris que l'avocat juan
branco a été mis en examen hier pour
viol elle intervient après les
accusations d'une jeune femme de 20 ans
fin avril j'avais l'ibuprofène 800 dans
une main et mon [ __ ] des repos de
gauche dans l'autre
et j'ai pris une gorgée de ma bouteille
d'eau et puis je me suis rendu compte
que c'était pas l'ibuprofène que j'avais
avalé
un manuscrit d'albert einstein vendu aux
enchères shanahan et oui il a été adjugé
à 11,6 millions d'euros avec les frais
c'est un montant record là